a bit of an update on the Phillips
Schofield story Holly Willoughby we
haven't heard from her she's just posted
an insta story and this is what it says
there you go it's taken time to process
yesterday's news when reports of this
relationship first surfaced I asked Phil
directly if this was true and was told
it was not it's been very hurtful to Now
find out that this was a lie Holly so
that is Holly Willoughby putting that up
on her insta stories and Instagram story
and that is following
um the resignation yesterday and that
statement in the daily mail from um
Phillip Schofield that he was quitting
ITV he wasn't going to do the British
soap Awards and that was after he said
that he um was having an affair with
someone who was considerably younger
than him a colleague
um he said that it was unwise but it was
not illegal and so that is the latest
from Holly Willoughby she has said it's
taken time to process yesterday's news
when reports of this relationship first
surfaced I asked Phil directly if this
was true and was told it was not it's
been very hurtful to Now find out that
this was a lie